Vladimir Putin es como tu jefe: no te cae
bien, no te fías de él pero le necesitas
para poder pagar el alquiler. Hacía tiempo
que no hablábamos de Rusia en VisualPolitik
y creo que ya sé lo que estáis pensando
¿Otra vez, Fonseca? ¿Otra vez nos vas a
hablar de petróleo? ¡Pues no! ¡Esta vez
vamos a hablar de GAS NATURAL!
Muchos pensaréis que son temas muy parecidos. A fin de cuentas, los países que tienen petróleo
también suelen tener gas natural. Pero hay
una sutil diferencia. El petróleo está mucho
más diversificado. Por ejemplo, Rusia suministra
el 30% del petróleo que llega a Europa, pero
hay mucho más suministradores. En el caso
del gas, hablamos de muchos menos y Rusia
supone un 40%. Pero, en muchos casos, la dependencia
es aún mayor. Por ejemplo, Alemania depende
en un 60% del gas ruso. Y otros países como
Finlandia o los bálticos dependen en un 100%
de Rusia. En otras palabras, que si Putin
quisiera, podría dejar a todos estos países
en mitad de un frío invierno que haría que
Juego de Tronos pareciera los vigilantes de
la playa.
¡Pero esperad un momento porque no sólo
hablamos de calefacción! En realidad, el
consumo de los hogares es sólo una tercera
parte del total.
Como podéis ver en esta gráfica, el otro
tercio, el de la franja morada, se destina
a la producción de electricidad en las centrales
de ciclo combinado.
Pero el grueso de la demanda de gas corresponde
a las empresas. Por ejemplo, una fábrica
de papel necesita, por un lado, energía eléctrica
pero también necesita energía TÉRMICA.
Es decir, calor. Para obtener ese calor, la
fábrica utiliza gas. Y lo mismo ocurre un
montón de industrias más.
En otras palabras: el gas es esencial para
Europa. Y el gas barato es esencial para que
las empresas de Europa sean competitivas ¿Y
quién es el principal consumidor de gas de
toda Europa? ¡Exacto! ¡Alemania! El país
con más población, pero, sobretodo, con
más industria de todo el continente. Y aquí
está la clave de la historia. Porque mientras
Alemania dependa de Rusia, toda Europa dependerá
de Rusia también. Y por eso, en la cumbre
de la OTAN de 2018, Donald Trump decía cosas
como esta:
“Alemania está totalmente controlada por
Rusia porque van a sacar entre un 60 y un
70% del gas en el nuevo gasoducto. Decís
que es apropiado pero yo creo que no. Y creo
que es malo para la OTAN”
Así que la pregunta es ¿Tiene razón Trump
en criticar a Alemania? ¿De verdad es un
problema que Europa dependa tanto del gas
ruso? Es más, ¿De verdad hay algún intento
para reducir esta dependencia? Hoy vamos a
responder a estas preguntas pero antes…
Vamos a ver un poco de historia.
NUESTRO HOMBRE EN BERLÍN
Hay dos formas de transportar el gas: la más
barata es a través del gasoducto. Es decir,
construimos una tubería gigantesca que va
desde el sitio donde se saca, por ejemplo,
el yacimiento de Yamal, en Rusia, hasta el
país que lo compra. Es un sistema muy barato
porque basta con construir la tubería y ¡Ya
está! No hacen falta camiones, ni barcos,
ni nada parecido. Según sale el gas, llega
a las casas y a las fábricas.
Pero hay otro método alternativo: el llamado
Gas Natural Licuado, también conocido por
sus siglas GNL ¿Cómo funciona este método?
Pues bien, imaginad que sacamos el gas de
un yacimiento en Qatar. Cuando sacamos el
gas, lo enfriamos hasta llegar a -161ºC.
A estas temperaturas, el gas se convierte
en líquido que podemos guardar en botellitas.
Esas botellitas las metemos en un barco metanero
que llega, por ejemplo, al Puerto de Barcelona,
en España. En Barcelona hay una planta regasificadora
que vuelve a calentar el líquido para convertirlo
en gas. Ese gas se enchufa a la red y llega
a fábricas y hogares ¿Cuál es la ventaja
de este proceso? Que permitiría que Europa
pudiera recibir gas de muchos otros sitios
¿Cuál es el problema? Que es entre un 50
y un 70% más caro que el gas que viene por
los gasoductos.
Y eso explica que los países europeos compren
el gas a los productores que tienen más cerca,
con los que están conectados por tuberías.
Por ejemplo, el principal suministrador de
España es Argelia. Sin embargo, los países
del Norte de Europa compran a Noruega y, sobretodo,
a Rusia. Como decíamos antes, empresas rusas
como ROSFNEFT o LUKOIL venden más de la mitad
del gas que se consume en Alemania ¿Y qué
pasa en los países que están entre Alemania
y Rusia? Pues que tienen una relación de
dependencia aún más profunda. Fijaos en
este mapa.
Si o fijáis, veréis que algunos Polonia
dependen en un 75% del gas ruso. Otros como
Finlandia o Rumanía llegan al 100%. En otras
palabras, que media Europa necesita a Rusia
para sobrevivir. Y esto no es ningún secreto.
La Comisión Europea lo sabe. Rusia lo sabe.
Y Putin también lo sabe. Incluso él lo sabe.
Alemania se volverá totalmente dependiente
de la energía rusa si no cambia de rumbo
de inmediato. Aquí en Occidente, estamos
comprometidos a mantener nuestra independencia
frente a la invasión de las potencias extranjeras
expansionistas.
Vamos a pausar el vídeo un momento. Justo
aquí, donde vemos a la delegación alemana
en las Naciones Unidas riéndose de Trump.
Fijaos que Donald Trump dice que Alemania
se va volver dependiente de la energía rusa.
Es decir, que si ya es dependiente, lo va
a ser aún más ¿A qué se refiere exactamente?
Vamos a rebobinar un momento.
Quedaos con este nombre: Gerhard Schröder.
Seguro que muchos ya lo conocéis. Se trata
del ex canciller alemán: el predecesor de
Ángela Merkel. Un hombre que todavía mantiene
una enorme influencia en la política alemana
y europea ¿Y a qué se dedica el señor Schröder
ahora mismo? Pues… es nada más y nada menos
que a construir esto.
“El ex presidente de la OTAN, Rasmusen dice
que Alemania entra en la trampa de Putin con
el Nord Stream 2”
Básicamente, el Nord Stream 2 es un nuevo
gasoducto que pasaría por debajo del mar
Báltico. Con esta nueva tubería, Alemania
duplicaría sus compras de gas ruso. Este
nuevo gasoducto tiene un comité de accionistas
donde hay varias empresas, entre otras, la
rusa GAZPROM. Y el presidente de ese comité
de accionistas es, nada más y nada menos,
que el señor Schröder. Por si esto fuera
poco, el ex canciller alemán es también
el presidente de ROSNEFT, una empresa petrolera
rusa. Eso explica que en los últimos 10 años,
Schröder se haya convertido en algo así
como el “hombre de Putin en Europa”. De
hecho, ha salido en defensa de Rusia en toda
clase de asuntos: desde los ciberataques a
Estonia hasta la ocupación de Crimea. En
otras palabras: que lejos de reducir su independencia
de Rusia, Alemania da pasos en la dirección
opuesta.
Así que ¿De qué se estaban riendo los alemanes?
Pues… la verdad es que no lo sé...
Pero ya me puedo imaginar lo que estaréis
pensando muchos… ¿Cuál es el problema
con depender de Rusia? ¿Qué Putin es un
líder autoritario? ¿En serio? Pfff… pues
casi mejor que no miremos al resto de proveedores:
Azerbaijan, Argelia, Qatar… vamos, todos
ellos son países gobernados por hermanitas
de la caridad.
Pues no. No se trata de democracia ni derechos
humanos. El problema con depender de Rusia
es otro. Ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
LA RUSO DEPENDENCIA
En el año 2006: la rusa Gazprom quiso multiplicar
por 6 el precio del gas para Ucrania. La cuestión
venía de antes, ya que Ucrania mantuvo una
relación bastante amistosa con Rusia hasta
la Revolución Naranja. ¿Os acordáis de
las disputas entre Víktor Yanukóvich y Víktor
Yúshchenko? (Puedes poner una foto de ambos)
Pues fue llegar este último al poder, con
un discurso antiruso y más proEuropeo y desde
el Kremlin empezaron a pensar: Con que esas
tenemos, Ucrania. Preparad la cuenta corriente
que esto no os va a salir barato.
Pensadlo bien, construir un gasoducto lleva
años. Así que Ucrania no podía buscar nuevos
proveedores de la noche a la mañana. Si Putin
quería, podía subir el precio todo lo que
quisiera ¿Qué Ucrania se niega a pagarlo?
¡Muy fácil: Rusia corta el grifo!
Durante tres días, en plena ola de frío,
los ucranianos se quedaron sin calefacción.
Y el caso se cerró con que Ucrania aceptó
pagar el doble de lo que venía pagando hasta
el momento. A cambio, subió el peaje que
le cobraba a Rusia por cruzar con sus gasoductos
el territorio ucraniano hacia Europa.
¡Pero esto sólo es el principio! En el año
2009, tuvimos el mismo problema, pero a lo
bestia. Rusia quería que Ucrania pagara más
por el gas. Kiev y Moscú se enzarzaron en
una ensalada de insultos. Y en este caso,
no sólo Ucrania se quedó sin gas: también
el resto de Europa: desde República Checa
hasta Italia, pasando por Polonia y, por supuesto
Alemania.
Nuevamente, la historia se cerró con que
Ucrania pagaba aún más por el gas Ruso pero,
a la vez, cobraban más como peaje por usar
su territorio para llegar al resto de Europa.
Sin embargo, como pasa en Juego de Tronos,
la canción de Putin es de hielo y fuego.
Así que tras dejar sin calefacción a millones
de europeos en 2006 y 2009, en 2014 fue el
turno del fuego. Y el fuego se lo llevó una
provincia ucraniana que se llama Crimea. Como
ya sabéis, Rusia invadió y se quedó con
Crimea. Si no lo sabéis, lo podéis ver en
este otro vídeo.
¿Y qué hizo la Unión Europea en este caso?
Pues básicamente, dijeron a Rusia: ¡Putin,
eres un chico muy malo! ¡Te vamos a poner
unas sanciones y nos vas a escribir 20 veces
“no invadiré otros países”. Pero ahí
se quedó la cosa. Ucrania es más un dolor
de cabeza que otra cosa.
Y por eso, tenemos dos opciones: la favorita
de Putin y de Schroeder es construir nuevo
gasoductos que sorteen Ucrania. Muerto el
perro, se acabó la rabia. La segunda es la
favorita de Jean Claude Juncker y la Unión
Europea: buscar otros productores de gas.
Pero… ¿de verdad es viable? Ahora mismo
lo vamos a ver.
INTENTOS DE DIVERSIFICACIÓN
La opción más rápida sería comprar Gas
Natural Liquado. Es caro, sí. Pero no hay
que esperar a construir nuevas tuberías ¿El
problema? Que los barcos metaneros están
demasiado ocupados suministrando a Asia. Básicamente,
el Pacífico está lleno de metaneros que
desde Australia, Qatar y Malasia abastecen
a Japón, China y Corea ¿La razón? En estos
países se paga mucho más por el gas. Así
países como Qatar o incluso Estados Unidos,
que serían potenciales suministradores de
Gas Liquado, prefieren mirar a Asia que a
Europa.
Y por eso, la alternativa más factible pero,
a la vez, más complicada, es la de construir
nuevos gasoductos. Y la pregunta es ¿Dónde?
Por un lado tenemos a Noruega, pero Europa
ya consume todo el gas que produce este país.
Si miramos más al Sur, España ha insistido
durante años en construir el MidCat, un gasoducto
con una capacidad para transportar a Europa
el gas que llega desde Argelia. Sin embargo,
Francia no está por la labor porque tendrían
que ser ellos los que construirían la red.
Y bueno “pfff, menuda liada, ya si eso…
es que mañana he medio quedado”.
Así que, por el momento, el proyecto más
serie es el llamado GASODUCTO TRANSADRIÁTICO
o TAP, que se terminará de construir en 2020.
Esta tubería parte de los impresionantes
yacimientos de Shah Deniz en Azerbaiyán,
para cruzar Turquía hasta llegar a Italia
¡Pero esperad un momento porque esto no es
suficiente! Esta tubería podría transportar
un máximo de 20.000 millones de metros cúbicos
de gas. Esto no es ni la mitad de lo que llegaría
a través del Nord Stream 2 que quiere construir
Rusia y Alemania.
Pero este no es el único problema. Porque
si pensabais que al Kremlin no le importa
este… intento de promiscuidad gasística…
estáis muy equivocados.
Gazprom asegura que el tránsito de gas a
través de Ucrania a Europa puede caer a 10-15
bcm por año
Con este movimiento, Putin mata dos pájaros
de un tiro. Por un lado, aprieta las tuercas
a Europa. Por el otro, consigue sortear a
Ucrania ¡Pero aquí no se queda la cosa!
En el Sur, Putin también está presionando
para crear nuevas tuberías. Y si pensabais
que Schroeder es el único amigo de Putin
en Europa, estáis muy equivocados.
Hungría quiere que el gasoducto TurkStream
se extienda a Europa
En las próximas semanas, vamos a cubrir dos
flecos que quedan en esta historia. Por un
lado, tenemos que hablar de Ucrania ¿hasta
qué punto Putin puede prescindir de Ucrania?
Por el otro, tenemos que hablar de Azerbaijan,
una dictadura con la que tal vez nos tengamos
que llevar bien. Pero de todo eso hablaremos
las próximas semanas, así que ya sabéis:
suscribíos a VisualPolitik y darle a la campanita
para no perderos ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones.
Mientras tanto, la pregunta es para vosotros:
¿De verdad quiere Europa reducir su dependencia
de Rusia? ¿O véis a Putin como Rey de la
Noche, con capacidad de convertir a todos
los europeos en caminantes blancos? Podéis
dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios
o en esta encuesta.
Y, por supuesto, no olvidéis visitar nuestra
página de Patreon, donde tendréis acceso
a contenido exclusivo. Por cierto, suscribíos
al canal de YouTube para no perderos ninguna
de nuestras actualizaciones y si os ha gustado
este vídeo, dadle a LIKE. Nos vemos en el
próximo. ¡Un abrazo y hasta pronto!